Let's go next to let's go to our caller from
the six one area code who's calling today
from 6 3 1.
They say the disadvantages.
Hey, Andrew, what's up?
Condeming.
Yeah.
Got it.
So I got a two part question.
First part is voter turnout in the primary
indicative and turnout in the general?
Well, it depends.
Not necessarily, I guess is the answer, so
you could have turnout elevated in the primaries
for a reason that doesn't translate to turnout
in the general.
So, for example, there may be a number of
candidates in the primary that are elevating
turnout, but then in the in the general there
may not be the same enthusiasm, for example.
So, no, I don't think I don't think that turnout,
primary turnout dictates general election
turnout, particularly in this time around
with the virus.
It's anyone's guess what's going to happen
with turnout.
How you turn out in this case is definitely
like up in the air.
Yeah, just not like, you know, in general.
Right.
Excluding a virus.
Yeah, I guess it's it's pretty complicated.
Also, do you have any ideas of how we can
encourage young voter turnout to me?
I mean, seeing the way Bernie ran his campaign
is like one of the most popular politicians
with young people breaking records and like
campaign contributions and still couldn't
get young people to vote, at least in the
primaries.
Who knows what can happen in the general.
But do you think we need to maybe introduce
some sort of legislation to get young people
to turn out?
Would that even look like.
No, I don't know about legislation I've talked
about.
You know, it's important to tell young people
that, you know, all of your activism is less
powerful if you're not also voting like you've
got to go actually vote.
When you don't vote, you are still voting.
You're still participating in the system.
The idea that you're opting out is a misnomer.
And when you don't vote, you are actually
still helping someone win.
But one interesting tactic I recently heard
and I'm gonna workshop this with you right
now, Andrew, is the following idea, the idea
of you are a shareholder in this country.
And when you become 18, your shares vest and
they become voting shares.
The amazing thing is there are people who
are much older than you who have the exact
same voting power as you do merely by turning
18.
Your share has vested and it is now a voting
share.
You're not going to throw that share out,
are you?
Because much like shares of stock in a company,
your share in this country which lets you
vote has value when you don't vote.
You're essentially throwing it out.
Now, in practice, you're doing something worse.
You may actually be letting the person you
really dislike become president.
But that's a different issue.
So I'm workshopping this shareholder ideology
as maybe a way to get people to understand
the importance of voting as soon as they're
old enough to.
Yeah, it's an interesting way to look at it.
Mm hmm.
I think a lot of young people might also not
think that their their vote or their share
really matters, especially if they're in like
a blue versus a red state.
I'm wondering if maybe if we had something
like I personally think the Electoral College
would still be in place.
But maybe if we didn't just it wasn't like
a given.
If one state just didn't give all their electoral
votes to one candidate.
Maybe if it was sort of like split, right?
Yeah.
I mean, another way to get a sort of partial
popular vote is you start you maintain the
electoral college, but you do proportional
allocation of electoral votes.
That's another idea.
But yeah.
Yeah, I think it's certainly.
Which I think is what you're suggesting.
These are all good ideas.
Yeah.
And this is a longtime thing.
Every election cycle, someone says the polls
are understating your youth support and this
candidate or that can.
That it's gonna crush it because of young
people.
And then the young people don't show up.
And then we have the same thing happen over
and over again.
Yeah, exactly.
All right, my friend.
Thanks so much for the call.
Yeah.
Appreciate hearing from you and very much
hope to hear from you again.
Give us a call back.
Let's go next to our caller.